hi I'm Eric vos and this is a breakdown
of Rick and Morty Season three Episode
seven the Rick lantus mix-up Rick and
Morty just pulled the best possible fast
one on us promising us this goofy
Atlantis Side adventure but instead
giving us the most narrative Lee dent
we're hosed bill deist episode yet with
the return of evil Morty and real quick
before I continue a big thanks to quid
for sponsoring this video
quid is an app that allows you to drag
and drop stickers onto text message
threads including the Rick and Morty
theme ones more info on that later but
in this video I'm gonna share all the
stuff I love about this episode and
before I get to the jokes and references
that you might have missed let's quickly
talk about this bold choice to spend an
entire episode away from our Rick and
Morty something the show has never done
and instead focus on these other Rick's
and Morty's in the Citadel by doing this
the show brings up the big question what
does a world design for enviros really
look like we've actually gotten glimpses
of the Citadel in season 1 and this
season's premiere but this episode gives
us a real look at the day-to-day life of
the city the writers split this up into
four storylines the presidential
campaign of a corrupt Morty and his
campaign manager a rookie cop Rick
joining a crooked veteran cop morty on a
shift for Morty's spending their last
day together on a trip to the wishing
portal and an oppressed cookie assembly
line worker whose stages a hostage
situation other than these stories
coming together to reveal the rise of
evil morty the results of all these is
to show how the world of rick contains
all the negative aspects of humanity and
heightens them to an extreme degree rick
actually warned us about this in the
opening scene anyone continuing to
explore the Citadel is either stupid or
one of the unfortunate millions held
hostage by their terrible ideas so in
Citadel the political process is broken
there's a huge wealth gap where workers
are oppressed for no reason the justice
system is full of corruption and Morty's
are second-class citizens despite all of
its technological advances it's only
natural that this society would
inevitably lead to disaster with one
extremely ambitious and manipulative
morty taking over but despite the change
that evil morty promises all of these
rick's and Morty's are just tricked by
an illusion of change when nothing
really changes in their world
blue-collar Rick believes the owner of
simple Rick's is
rating him but ironically his freedom
traps him into a life where he's
enslaved with his freedom memories
flavoring the new wafer cookies ha prick
begins the episode with a Morty's style
innocent point of view and despite
thinking that he broke the cycle of
corruption by killing cop Morty he ends
up getting released and free to go the
cycle continues and the Morty kids
believe Slick Morty throwing himself
into the wishing portal was him
fulfilling his own wish of changing the
cycle closing their school down but
really it was just evil Morty's election
that did that and as far as we can tell
evil Morty intends on keeping all the
Morty's and bricks in the Citadel in the
same cycle of oppression so really all
of these tales form a macrocosm
reflecting our Rick's relationship with
our Morty a cycle of oppression where
just when it seems like things have been
changed for the better we begin the next
episode of right where we left off so
while this episode seems like it's not
at all about our Rick and Morty it
actually is about them very much so also
this episode is titled the Rick Lantis
mix-up just seemingly a red herring to
their dumb journey to the underwater
city of Atlantis that we never get to
see but if you think about it Atlantis
is a fictional city from the works of
the Greek philosopher Plato he conceived
Atlantis as an allegory on the hubris of
nations the arrogance of trying to build
a utopia that is ultimately what the
Rick lantus mix up is all about a
utopian society which due to its own
hubris eventually descends toward its
own doom now the alternate title for
this episode was originally tales from
The Citadel and this whole idea of
spending an episode on a bunch of other
alternate short stories about people
other than the main characters it's
inspired by a classic episode of The
Simpsons 22 short films about
Springfield the way this episode
transitions in and out of each
overlapping storyline borrows directly
from that pulp fiction a plot structure
of that Simpsons episode let's actually
point out all the cultural references
and influences for this episode in our
segment under the influence so this was
obviously an extremely political episode
of Rick and Morty so there are a ton of
references to realize political events
actually in the opening scene the
visiting Rick says this
the policeman's ball to a black teenager
here so this is a reference to the
real-world tensions between police and
black youth a theme that actually plays
a major role in the police ride-along
storyline with more T's depicted as
second-class citizens in a slum who
taunt their fellow Morty for his cop
uniform all of these scenes definitely
are influenced by things like training
day the wire and Straight Outta Compton
evil Morty is also obviously drawing
from real-life political figures his
speech echoes the famous quote from
Franklin D Roosevelt he also preached it
is that he refuses to see the Citadel as
divided invoking Barack Obama's famous
speech in 2004 the division I see is
between the Rick's and Morty's that like
the Citadel divided and the rest of us
there are those who are preparing to
divide us there is not a liberal America
and a conservative America there is the
United States of America but if you look
closely even Morty's real strategy is a
lot less inspirational on the dry erase
board in his campaign office he wrote
the Morty advantage with alternate news
sources and a divided Citadel now
obviously alternate in quotes there is a
reference to the fake news that played a
big role in the recent u.s. presidential
election also the Secret Service Rick
says this at the end of the episode it
was a blowout but hardly call it a
blowout it was almost close enough to
trigger a recount Jesus what are you
tube security now to kind of like how
our presidential election was decided by
less than 80,000 votes spread across
three states and electoral popular vote
split close enough for some people to
demand a recount
quite other claims that it was a
landslide now I should say that evil
Morty is largely pulling from fictional
political figures his cold suave
demeanor as he pours himself scotches
straight up Frank Underwood and house of
cards also this plot point of a secretly
evil presidential candidate nearly
getting assassinated is also something
that happens in house of cards as well
as the movies The Manchurian Candidate
and Bob Roberts also notice that even
Morty gets his hair trimmed and then
makes that awesome double entendre after
killing his
Advisors yes enough off the top don't
know is it yes yes yes I'm thinking this
could be a reference to De Niro's Al
Capone power play and The Untouchables
when he got groomed during meetings now
there are other characters who were
pulled from real-life political figures
the Rick guilt red candidate is a parody
of the candidate for New York governor
Jimmy rent is too damn high McMillan who
was surprisingly not fictional the rent
is too damn high
and then there's plumber Rick this guy
is modeled on Joe the Plumber a guy who
got an argument with Obama in the 2008
campaign
I've worked hard I'm a plumber also I'm
pretty sure the Rick on president
Morty's executive board is based on the
latest eve jobs actually in real life
heads of industry have been known to
serve on various president's economic
councils then there's another board
member wearing Middle Eastern garb kind
of like the members of OPEC who pulled
the strings behind a lot of government
leaders and one final possible political
influence I spotted was investigator
Rick who could be a reference to the
informant character deep throat in the
movie all the president's men you'll
notice he actually ends up floating
outside the airlock dead at the end of
the episode which is obviously this
episode's darkest moment now the story
line with the four younger more T's was
pretty clearly influenced by the movie
stand by me based on Stephen King's
short story the body where four boys who
look pretty similar to these guys go off
in search of a dead body and there were
a bunch of other sillier cultural
references icon the Morty's professor in
the Moore Academy was clearly influenced
by Severus Snape from the Harry Potter
books and movies and the statue in front
of the Academy kind of resembles the one
from the Ministry of Magic and Harry
Potter also kind of looks like the
Statue of Walt Disney and Mickey and
Disney World the head of simple Rick's
Rick D Sanchez the third is a rigged
version of Willy Wonka notice how his
purple top hat is the company logo
exactly how Wonka's hat is a logo for
the candy brand and if you look closely
there's also a Doctor Who Rick walking
around the Citadel doctor who is
arguably a pretty major influence on the
cosmic sci-fi humour of Rick and Morty
later on the farmer Rick's robot dog
kinda actually looks like canine from
Doctor Who there's also this goofy look
and Rick this is a Caesar Flickerman
Rick a reference to the over-the-top
media personality from The Hunger Games
series then there are also the variant
Rick
Rick 7/16 7/16 B and 7/16 C with
increasing amount of scar tissue on
their faces
Joel Vincent on Twitter actually pointed
out that those could be a references to
Tom axons a mod from GI Joe finally the
creepy morty club is full of fun
animation details including the
references of this morty with no
contrast lines which could be a South
Park Morty there's also this morty
wearing jeans and a red vest which might
be a Marty McFly Morty the character of
Morty was actually based on Justin
roiland animated shorts the real animate
Adventures of dr. Marty which parodied
Back to the Future actually recently
made a video that went into this
interesting origin story they should
definitely go watch alright let's move
on
early in episode the commercial of
simple Rick's is showing this image of
young Beth in the background with the
horse now this is obviously a callback
to Beth's lifetime love of horses and
her future career as a horse surgeon and
as always this Rick and Morty episode is
full of continuity references to past
episodes so let's break them all down in
our section call back in the news
footage of evil Morty meeting with
supporters one of the Morty's is a trunk
person remember in Rick's T minutes in
season 1 drunk people were introduced as
a politically marginalized group hi I'm
a trunk person and I won I feel love in
my heart too just like you
then there's another Morty supporter
with a reference to season one with this
sign reading nobody exists on purpose
remember that was a line for Morty's
speech in the same Rick's team in this
episode nobody exists on purpose nobody
belongs anywhere everybody's gonna die
come watch TV then for Morty's who try
to steal mega seeds from a mega tree
those were from the pilot episode notice
how the farmer Rick chews on a mega tree
sprout instead of a piece of straw and
at the end of the episode we see these
same Morty's in new uniforms harvesting
these seeds I'm wondering if they're
gathering these to improve the cognitive
powers of all the Morty's at least
before their motor functions and speech
start to go away also when the
blue-collar recruits his boss to death
the boss has a Shoney's mug that's a
callback to these seasons premiere when
we learn that Shoney's it's Rick's
favorite restaurant it's great to have
you back no matter where we are but
wouldn't you like to go home emotionally
speaking honey Shoney's is my home now
later in the drug-dealer Rick's
apartment in morty town the Morty's have
written gets
whip tea on the wall obviously that's a
reference to get schwifty in season 2
those more days also say this line of
there Rick hey Rick man when there's a
morty president you gonna lick my balls
or what that is a reference to Rick's
false memory catchphrase and total Rick
Hall and that was another reference to
Dakin Marty the super filthy short about
Rick and Morty that it was based on and
stick your tongue in my balls
I'm a doctor Marty recipe Marty again
check out my video explaining that
origin story now the closing shot of
this episode reveals the evidence that
the campaign manager Morty saw that the
president is actually evil Morty Morty
with the eyepatch whom we saw at the end
of closer accounts of the Rick kind this
episode actually foreshadowed that twist
in a couple interesting ways one was
during this press conference scene
what's your original reality and where's
your Rick gosh we moved around so much
it's hard to remember I see every Rick
is my Rick now at this point red flags
should have definitely been going up
because even Morty has no known Rick
counterpart his Rick was just a cyborg
being controlled by him remotely and
before I get to the other moment that
set this up the reason we get to make
this video is because QuIDD is
sponsoring it
big thanks to quit quit is an awesome
new app where you can collect cool
stickers cards and Funko pop figures for
free all on your phone if you use emojis
and stickers when you text your friends
quit has thousands of free stickers that
you can't find anywhere else from hot
shows like the just release Game of
Thrones Rick and Morty Steven universe
Bob's Burgers Powerpuff Girls and Family
Guy
also cold hits like Breaking Bad and
Star Trek and from games like five
nights at Freddy's and fallout you can
drag and drop these stickers and
iMessage it's a breezy look I'm making
Rick and Morty yellow my text at each
other my life is interesting now now
some of these stickers cards and toys
are super rare and hard to get so good
luck but the good news is that you can
meet cool people on quit look at their
collections and trade with them just as
easily and as quickly as chatting with
each other there's also a new feature
you can showcase your collection by
adding stickers to images you already
have in your camera roll whose stickers
cards and figures that you can collect
for free are released every day
including a surprise big news show
coming soon so yeah jump on this ok back
to evil Morty at the beginning of the
episode there's this little exchange I
was never on board with it in the first
place that's why I murdered everyone in
charge and left it to rot
Oh
that was you I think there's more to
this exchange and I may be totally wrong
but let's dig into this with theory time
okay now that we know that evil Morty is
president of the Citadel it makes all of
the Citadel especially dangerous even
more dangerous to rick than before
actually since the council of ricks
previously governed it this is the
Citadel's first time operating under
this kind of authority system which the
visiting Morty actually hints at in the
scene well you'll be happy to know that
the council's gone now he knows he
murdered them however notice how the
visiting Rick and Morty didn't initially
realize that these were the guys who
wiped out the Citadel that's because
this isn't our Rick and Morty's home
dimension remember their c-137 Rick and
Morty
all right Morty here we are oh my god
and that world got Cronenberg so they
had to bail on it move to this one so
they've essentially been living in
hiding from the Citadel this whole time
but now by bragging about killing the
council of ricks to these visitors rick
has outed his position to the Citadel
they know what dimension he lives in now
and I think this will be how evil Morty
finds Rick by the end of the season FAK
noticed what the episode description for
the finale episode of so tennis rick has
a confrontation with the president so
yeah guys I think this is all headed
toward a big epic showdown between these
two brilliant Psychopaths now if you
miss those clues I think everyone
recognized evil Morty's return with the
spooky evil Morty theme music coming
back at the end of the episode
[Music]
let's actually take a quick second to
talk about the music of this episode
besides the evil Morty theme this
episode opens with another well-known
track in the city by the Eagles the
lyrics are perfectly appropriate for
this theme in this episode that despite
the illusion of change at these Morty's
experience they remained trapped in
these same shitty place the other songs
sample in this episode that you might
have recognized is this music that plays
in cop Morty's police car as they patrol
Morty town this is actually the theme
song for grand theft auto san andreas
[Music]
moving on even more than usual this
episode is packed with missable
animation details and jokes in the
background campaign propaganda Morty
graffiti logos for simple Rick's food
let's look even more closely and point
out some of the more interesting details
in our segment do it in this okay first
off I love all the detail that went into
the background Rick's and Morty's of
this episode there was this Morty at the
campaign rally with this haircut I guess
I'm just gonna call that a flattop
uptown fade I don't know what their cuts
are called also in the creepy Morty's
Club there's this Morty with glasses
apparently that's a Morty designed to
look like Justin roiland later on
there's a reporter Morty who's an
old-timey journalist with a bowler hat
and a mustache also zooming and
enhancing on the background of Rick's
campaign office you can see that his
campaign website is oh jeez calm then at
the Morty Academy there's a Latin phrase
in the chalkboard that reads motto
autumn diem ACTA non verba which
translates to motto of the day actions
not words which is ironic because a
motto of the day is literally words
instead of actions look I made a joke
funnier by explaining it the school also
has a recycle bin with Morty's pace in
the logo which I love because that's
exactly what the Rick's due to the
Morty's at the Citadel they just recycle
them and swap them around and pretty
much all of the logos we see in this
episode are references like pop Rick
drinks coffee from cafe Sanchez which
has a similar logo to Starbucks
there's also hard Rick cafe instead of
Hard Rock Cafe and a more tea eating
from a Morty's bag which has a
McDonald's type golden arches logo
finally I love the design for evil
Morty's presidential seal which shows up
on his mirror
in banners and the new uniforms at the
end of the episode it uses the old
citadel logo which previously had an r'
shape cutting through it for Rick now
evil Morty has added an end to it with
the middle strokes stabbing down through
the are like a pitchfork or a sigh this
is reflecting the Citadel as it is now
with Morty on top in a threatening
position over the Rick's that oppressed
him for so long who do you think is the
bigger threat to Rick now evil Morty or
bird person and Tammy who showed up at
the end of episode 1 or is it Rick
himself also because we'd love you guys
new rock stars is gonna do a special
giveaway just for you guys where if you
follow us on Twitter and then share this
video on Twitter with the hashtag new
Rick stars we'll pick a couple of you at
random and said you guys free Rick and
Morty Funko pop vinyl figures so get on
this guy's sure this far and wide and
thank you so much for watching these and
if you'd like to help us make more of
these videos maybe so that we can one
day afford to do these without
interrupting them with ads you can
contribute to us on patreon big thanks
to all of our current donors especially
Kelly hopper
so yeah share this video subscribe to
new rockstars and tweet me your thoughts
a ta vas or new rock stars at new rock
stars alright thanks for watching bye